hey before we get started I want to
thank black desert for generously
sponsoring this video
black desert is an online MMORPG that
really stands out from the competition
you can build your own custom character
from scratch there are 16 diverse
classes to choose from and the character
creation system is so detailed it's
crazy I basically created Lord to eagle
he who transcends dimensions and worlds
and thanks to the easy-to-use beginners
tutorial I was able to jump right into
the game and only a few minutes black
desert features real-time action based
combat which includes fast paced combos
and diverse weapons and fighting styles
that make it an absolute joy to play the
graphics are just stunning
don't take my word for it you have to
see it for yourself and as a huge fan of
fantasy and medieval history I was
hooked right away the game is constantly
being updated and a brand new expansion
pack has just been released featuring a
large mountainous area with over 300
quests to complete and there's even a
freaking dragon boss to take on a worthy
foe for the mightiest of men Lord we go
Samus and say try it out for yourself
just click the link in the description
for a free 7-day trial and you'll see
exactly why I'm loving this game right
now
[Music]
what up guys goes on here for anime
uproar and today we are adding yet
another video to the MHA fact series
today we are going to be talking about
the darkest hero out there
fumika gay one of my favorite characters
this video was suggested by a lot of you
both on YouTube and on Instagram he was
the most voted for character after baku
go a video that I did a while back for
this series you decide which videos I do
so let me know who you want to see next
in the comments and check the MHA facts
series playlist which I'll link in the
description and at the end of the video
to make sure you don't suggest a
character that's already been covered if
you like this series make sure United
States have smash that like button to
let me know and if you haven't make it a
triple combo by smashing the subscribe
button and notification about to join
our plus ultra fam without further ado
let's get into some dark facts fact
number one first up let's talk about
fumika gaze name if you watch my other
videos you know by now that hoodie core
she always tries to make sure that the
names of his characters match them
and/or their quirks in one way or
another this is practically always the
case but Western viewers may miss that
because the names have meanings in the
Japanese language but not necessarily in
English for example midoriya has Midori
in his name which means green this
reflects both the colour of his hair and
hero costume maybe it even hints at the
fact that he's a greenhorn or in other
words a new beat which is what my hero
academia is all about watching these
novices grow into pro heroes similarly
Foo macaques names were definitely
designed specifically for him to cleome
his family name means eternal darkness
or despair the word Yami shouldn't be
anything new for anime fans
you might remember it from yugioh where
yami-yugi direct translation dark Yugi
referred to Yugi's alternate identity
that of the Pharaoh even in black clover
the lovable black bull's captain is
named Yami which reflects his dark magic
powers even though it's fumika gaze
family name the name fits him perfectly
for instance fumika gaze quirk is dark
shadow a shadow like creature shaped
like a bird that grows stronger the
it gets in fact if it's dark enough dark
shadows power is potentially limitless
and fumika gay has trouble even
controlling it a major issue which can
potentially lead to you guessed it
despair not to mention boom akagi's
usual attitude which can totally be
described as dark at the very least no
one would say he's a happy-go-lucky
character next we turned to his given
name
fumika gay which is no less customized
to fit his character you may recognize
the word cog a from Naruto like in
Hokage Kazakh gay and so on if you
didn't know the word means shadow again
the word shadow reflects his quirk which
is a shadow but it also reflects fumika
gay himself who enjoys spending time in
the shadows ie
in dark places the Fumi part contains
the Japanese character for step put
together with cog a the name could
roughly translate to one who walks in
the shadows a perfect name for a dark
Birdman lastly his chosen hero named
tsukuyomi comes from tsukuyomi know
makoto the moon god in japanese
mythology so we get another reference to
the dark this time the night
specifically and the gods story is
depressing or in other words dark as
well since it is said that he killed ok
mochi the goddess of food which angered
the sun goddess who was his wife and
also his sister the sun goddess got mad
and moved to another part of the sky
which is why day and night are never
together so to Kiyomi was left alone in
the dark now tell me that there's a
character darker than fumika again my
hero academia you can't because he's
darker than black he is eternal darkness
fact number 2
fumika gaze seems to be obsessed with
not only dark stuff but religious stuff
as well he seems too costly be
associated with dark and religious
references for example I already
mentioned how his hero name references
the moon God which is part of the Shinto
religion when we see his dark gloomy
room we also see crosses they're
obviously a symbol from Christianity in
one of his character profiles in the
manga lady cause she says that fumika he
likes dimly lit places another way of
saying darker places and apples
a fruit that has great symbolic value in
Christianity even the anime Death Note
picks up on this as gods of death love
apples and light in the intro bytes an
apple symbolizing the loss of innocence
and his own desire to become a god
lastly fumika gay has one move called
black fallen angel yet another reference
to Christianity and a move called black
UNK and an ankh is another religious
symbol and object resembling a cross but
having a loop at the top it comes to us
from ancient Egypt and it was used as a
symbol of life yet another thing that
you might recognize from yugioh thus
phool makhani likes combining darkness
with religious symbols
I find all of this to be interesting and
I think it foreshadows how powerful for
me cago can potentially become now take
a second to appreciate that amazing pun
in the previous sentence before we move
on to back number three for this fact
let's talk about fumika gaze popularity
in Japan birdboy fumika GAE ranked
seventh in the first popularity poll
right after frog girl to you this was
pretty impressive considering how many
awesome characters are in this series
however he couldn't remain in the top
ten he dropped to 15th in the second
poll and then up to 13th in the third
there was actually a metafictional bonus
manga in the fourteenth volume where the
my hero academia characters were
commenting on their place in the second
annual popularity ranking who akagi's
stoic lee says i dropped while coming
ari says at least we didn't drop as much
as him referring to Moneta who went from
18th in the first poll all the way down
to 31st in the second and of course mean
it does not stoic at all as he is shown
totally freaking out in the same volume
the top 10 most popular characters got
shown wearing fantasy inspired outfits
and in the back of the volume we have
another metafictional moment where mina
says we the less popular characters
wanted to dress up as knockoff fantasy
characters - and so horikoshi gives some
of the less popular characters including
fumika gay their own two-page spread
wearing their own fantasy outfits
however poor Mineta even gets left out
of this page I gotta say though I love
that horikoshi gives us this matter
fictional
material in the manga volumes I think
it's hilarious
and it gives some more attention to the
characters that don't get enough next
let's talk about the popularity polls in
the West in the first English popularity
poll fumika also got seven but in the
second one he only fell one spot to
eighth place
similarly in crunchyroll 2018 popularity
poll he got eighth place
- so he's consistently been in the top
ten in the West let me know if he's in
your top ten but I gotta say he's
definitely in mine
fact number four if you ask for Akashi
the creator of my hero academia who the
coolest character in the series is he
would say for me cago he wrote that he
thinks he's cool beyond cool in vol 12
he also points out that for me cago
wears a joke around his neck and that
that's cool as well in short
horikoshi would give the coolest
character award to fumika gay but at the
same time he finds it tough to deal with
fumika gay because he doesn't quite fit
into the rest of the world compared to
the others horikoshi says that he really
struggles with him and I completely get
where he's coming from
I joked in a previous video where I
explained every class one a student in
ten words or less that fool me cago is
what would happen if Bruce Wayne ie
Batman fell into a chicken coop instead
of a cave where he was attacked by bats
I purposely compared foo me cago to
Batman because they're very similar and
I love fumika GAE in large part because
I love Batman he was always my favorite
superhero to the point where I used to
introduce myself as Batman when I was a
kid no joke however Batman fits into his
world his dark personality meshes well
with the dark city of Gotham however the
world of MHA is not as dark and fumika
gay is a teenager surrounded by other
often more lighthearted teenagers as a
result he comes off as someone trying to
be like Batman rather than just being
like Batman and instead of coming off as
cool sometimes he just ends up being
used for comedic purposes for instance
when his room is shown fumika gay has to
be shoved out of the way and then
Kanishka comments that he remembers
buying keychains like the ones from ACOG
he has in his room
in middle school fumika he is
embarrassed and wants them to be gone as
he says thus although his room might
come off as cool in a different context
and that could the character most likely
cause she finds it cool himself in the
world of MHA the room comes off as kind
of embarrassing and even childish UA is
in Gotham and there's a disconnect
between fumika gaze dark seriousness and
the often light-hearted atmosphere of
the school so hoody cause she still
thinks from ACOG a is cool but he
understands that not everyone in the
world of my hero academia would see
fumika gay in the same dim light fact
number five although fumika gay is a lot
like Batman it would seem that most of
the inspiration for his character came
from a different source
there is one Western hero that has even
more in common with our dark bird and
that's so raven but jokes aside i am of
course referring to Raven from DC Comics
I've commented in my to you video how
our beloved frog girl is a lot like the
western supervillain toad except when he
caught she took the powers and gave them
to a cute high school girl instead we
have a similar situation here Raven and
fumika Gaye have a lot of things in
common they're both associated with
birds and darkness they both have shadow
like powers that take the form of a bird
and both of them struggle with their
dark Opie powers trying to keep them
under control and if that wasn't enough
they both wear cloaks and have dark
colored hero costumes I like both of
these characters and Raven is my
favorite Teen Titan so these
similarities make me like fumika gay all
the more fact number 6 let's talk about
dark shadow and fumika gaze hero costume
hero costumes are usually made with the
individual's quirk in mind which is why
Mina has acid-proof boots that allow her
to use her quirk to slide across the
ground and whyme almost hero costume
shows us much skin as possible so she
can easily pop out her creations Bhoomi
kagaz costume is also customized to work
with his quirk dark shadow is powered by
darkness in fact
horikoshi said that a dark shadow who
has been used continuously in bright
places will eventually run out of energy
and get a
is really weak so weak in fact that he
says a weakened dark shadow is more
useless than a cockroach so in order to
keep dark shadows strong toka Yami wears
a long shade providing Cape as part of
his hero costume the shade provided
under his cape ensures that dark shadow
can power up to an extent even in the
daylight but even so let's just take a
minute to appreciate that fumika yay got
third place in the you a sports festival
where the laches took place over the
course of the day a circumstance that
weakens his quirk and that the person he
lost against was Baku go whose quirk
produces life and thus further weakens
dark shadow if fumika gay learns to
control nighttime full beast mode dark
shadow he'll definitely be one of the
strongest characters in my hero academia
fact number seven all right now let's
look at some good old-fashioned
statistics in the official data book
fumika gay scored a 2 out of 5 in power
and what he caught she even notes that
his arms are fairly thin I suppose since
dark shadow does most of the fighting
for him fumika he has disregarded his
own physical training which is not good
you know that Batman would never do that
and speaking of Batman unfortunately
fumika gay didn't get Batman's
genius-level intellect he only scored a
3 out of 5 in intelligence in speed he
also got a 3 out of 5 and a technique he
got a solid 4 out of 5 perhaps most
surprisingly fumika gay who seems like
he would be a lone wolf type scored a
perfect 5 out of 5 in cooperativeness
even Kirishima the man who can make
friends with Lord
explosion murder himself only managed to
get a 4 so props to fumika gay for that
fact number 8 in the Japanese swimming
cog he is voiced by the 36 year-old
award-winning voice actor yoshimasa
Hosea Hosea is from Hiroshima Japan and
as well as being a sail or Japanese
voice actor he is also a singer he won
twice at the say u Awards for Best
Supporting Actor you may recognize him
as the complicated rider from attack on
Titan or as the awesome Olga
from Mobile Suit Gundam iron blooded
orphans to name a few of his voice
acting gigs back number nine in the
English fumika he is voiced by the 32
year old Joshua Grell a man from Texas
USA now you know that's a sign to Texas
smash that like button if you're
enjoying the video so far you may
recognize the voice as the
quick-thinking Armand from attack on
Titan and as the legendary Kenichi from
konnichi the mightiest disciple shout
out two breaks from all-day anime who
will never stop telling everybody he
meets to immediately watch Kenichi fact
number 10 this is usually a lightning
round where I say a bunch of facts in
lieu of just one fact so you guys get
some bonus facts up in here
however instead of calling it a
lightning round we'll call it an eternal
darkness round this time in
consideration of fumika GAE in his
dislike of bright things okay ready set
three two one let's jam
fumika gaze blood type is a bee he's a
hundred fifty eight centimeters or five
foot two inches tall which places him
right between our choco and Minah
meaning he's actually the shortest guy
in the class after my boy Minah tough
fumika gay dresses surprisingly casual
when he is not wearing his school
uniform or his hero costume Bumi Kanye's
birthday is on October 30th just a day
before Halloween which reflects his dark
and spooky room and personality along
with his bird head which would always
seem out of place to us except maybe on
Halloween and finally at first glance in
the manga you might not notice from
Akane when the students are working on
strengthening their quirks during the
forest training camp arc we see most of
those other students training but for me
cago is seemingly nowhere to be found
later in the manga volume horikoshi
explains that if you look closely there
is in fact the scream coming from a cave
and that very scream comes from the dark
bird Lord Himself
fumika he is in the cave training to
control dark shadow in complete darkness
bonus fact fumika he is my second
favorite character to pick after
Todoroki in my hero once justice game
and you can watch me my brother Anna Mac
played that game by following us on
twitch at annum
uproar link in the description and that
is that I hope you guys enjoyed the
first ever eternal darkness round thank
you so much for watching I really do
appreciate it make sure you Texas smash
that like button if you enjoyed this
video and make it a triple combo by
smashing that subscribe button and
ringing that magic YouTube valve so you
don't miss any of these videos in the
future remember to leave your
suggestions for future MHA videos in the
comments definitely check out black
desert link in the description thank you
to them again for sponsoring this video
and have yourselves a plus ultra day
until next time see dark space cowboy
[Music]
you